welcome to the billionaire mindset your
30-day journey to
thinking like a billionaire now you can
just watch this video or if you want to
sign up for the entire series for free
and get the bonus pdf
companion calendar check the link in the
description below today is day seven and
we're gonna learn
how you can think like a billionaire
enjoy
[Music]
18 years ago in my apartment i
told the 18 founders that one day we
will build up a site
this site will be the top 10 sites of
the world
and we will build up a company that can
last
a hundred and two years and people say
why
102 years because our company was born
in 1999.
last year we had one year this
century we finished 100 years and next
century we have a one year 102 means
cross three centuries when
every goal you give to your team should
be very accurate
if you say ah this company is going to
last 100 years so
nobody take it seriously because every
company say
we want to last 100 years the number you
give the team
should be very accurate we took the
video when i talked to the 18 founders
and today when i watched the video a lot
of people say
well since we don't have anything to do
when you see 102 years a big 10 sites
that should do it
very few people believe that we will
make it happen
because we don't have high resumes right
i graduated from hanzo teaches college
and most of my colleagues at 18 founders
they were my students
my friends none of them are very
successful among the 18 people
there are only three people who know
something about
computer the rest of 15 people know
nothing about computer
nothing about the internet we had a no
money
18 people gather thousand dollars
and we had a no relationship none of us
from rich family or powerful family with
a government office
background we don't have a great talents
so i told the team that guys
if we can be successful 80 percent
of the young people in the world can be
successful
because at that time china had a note
the internet was so
backwards nobody believed e-commerce in
china
nobody believed internet people say
china will not develop internet and
china will not have e-commerce because
you don't have a credit card system
you don't have logistics you don't have
this you don't have that
but i think someday china will have
if we start to do it now if we prepare
for 10-15 years
the day that e-commerce in china
were booming so that was the uh
that was the thinking at the beginning
you better stay on top of yourself
and and really measure unless people
measure themselves you don't get any
better you cannot
succeed unless you are really holding
yourself
accountable and owning outcomes believe
me i've seen plenty of people at
microsoft various places in the tech
industry
brilliant people who when it came time
to execute and actually count
success and maybe not so much
maybe not so much you get in order to do
that
you have to actually know what the goal
is if the goal was to get the 450
million users
and then sell to facebook whatsapp did a
hell of a job
right i mean that that's not a i mean
it's a hell of a job at 19 billion 55
people that's a hell of a job
but you have to decide what outcome do
you want
bill gates was offered seven and a half
million dollars to sell all of microsoft
in 1979.
it would have been a rich guy if he had
taken it
richer if he didn't but a rich guy but
even putting that aside the impact on
society wouldn't have been the same
we had discussions with facebook about
buying facebook but zuckerberg knew
what he viewed as a an outcome that he
really desired and was willing to put in
the blood sweat and tears just like we
were
so execution and measurement are
hugely important and yet people let
themselves
off the hook what are the things you
think about that make companies
successful
in this type of environment versus those
that struggle
well i think it starts with us having
a long-term view rather than a
short-term view
and always thinking of how we can be
successful long-term by creating value
with for others starting with our
customers
and employees and so
when we look at it that way there's
always
uncertainty so it starts with being
prepared with that
and and recognizing that the future
is unknown and unknowable so the way we
have
prepared ourselves for that is focusing
on building capabilities that will be
make us successful under a whole variety
of conditions which means
having more flexibility more optionality
more diversity and so those are the
things that
we've always tried to do and so the
starting point
is is building capabilities that will
enable us to create
value with others starting with our
customers and then
finding the opportunities or the sets of
customers for whom we can create the
most value
and then as we do not resting on our
laws but
recognizing the future is going to be
different than the past
then continually improving and adding to
those capabilities
and as we do then we see oh with those
capabilities
we can now pursue additional
opportunities
and then as we start pursuing those
opportunities we realize well we need
additional capabilities so we add still
more capabilities
so this creates what i've called a
virtuous cycle of mutual benefit
where it's continual improvement
and growth and and diversity
certainly during the time i was at
harvard
i wasn't sure what i was going to do uh
the idea that software was this field
that uh
was the opportunity was unbelievable
that became more
obvious during the three year period i
was here
but my dad had been a lawyer i thought
of mathematics
you know like doing well in the putnam
that was the coolest thing uh
and the computer software i didn't think
those
people were as smart as the math people
so it's like well
am i going to go into the easy field or
this really hard field but
uh anyway math uh was fantastic
when i finally picked and decided to go
do microsoft then i
got into a period from age uh
19 uh to about 40
where i wasn't able to look at the
latest on
you know how tornadoes work or how
mitochondria work
i was pretty monomaniacal and when i was
able to
ask steve this is the year 2000 c balmer
uh he he mistakenly graduated
uh but then he started it stan
but i was trying to hire him but his
parents told him you're supposed to
graduate which was fine
but then he started at stanford business
school
and he was in his first year and i
thought this is perfect i'll get him to
drop out of
stanford business school uh so in a
certain sense he is a dropout
uh uh and he was very key to the success
of microsoft i mean
uh he knew a lot of things but during
that period i didn't get to do much
at harvard you know i took all these
courses because
it was just so amazing that people were
interested in talking about them
and i i have to say
i never went to a lecture during reading
period or any anything because the
courses that i was actually signed up
for i finally started
to work on those so i was in halal the
minute would open
to the minute it would close during
reading period trying to catch up on
on that other set of courses so people
say i'm a dropout which
is literally true but
because i like college courses the
online
college courses there's a company called
the learning company that i buy
uh tons and tons of their stuff and i do
you know at least four or five courses a
year
in a sense i like uh going to college
more than anyone
so i've sort of made sure my job
certainly post microsoft that i get to
spend my time meeting with scientists
learning new things
you know seeing what the hard problems
are in some cases giving money to people
to take on
those very very hard problems one of the
things that really
hurt apple was after i left john scully
got a very serious disease
and that disease i've seen other people
get it too it's
um it's the disease of thinking that
a really great idea is ninety percent of
the work
and that if you just tell your all these
other people
you know here's this great idea then of
course they can go off and make it
happen
and the problem with that is is that
there's a just a tremendous amount of
craftsmanship
in in between a great idea and a great
product
and as you evolve that great idea it
changes and grows it never comes out
like it starts because you learn a lot
more as you get into the subtleties of
it and you also find
there's tremendous trade-offs that you
have to make i mean you know there are
there are just certain things you you
can't make electrons do there are
certain things you can't make plastic do
or glass do
and and as you get in or factories do or
robots do
and as you get into all these things
designing a product is keeping
5 000 things in your brain
these concepts and fitting them all
together
in in kind of continuing to push to fit
them together in new and different ways
to get what you want and every day you
discover something new
that is a new problem or a new
opportunity to fit these things together
a little differently
and it's that process
that is the magic um
and so we had a lot of great ideas when
we started
but what i've always felt
that a team of people doing something
they really believe in is like is like
when i was a young kid
um there was a um a widowed man
that lived up the street and uh
he was in his 80s
he's a little scary looking and and i
got to know him a little bit
um i think he might have paid me to cut
his mow his lawn or something
and one day he said come on into my
garage i want to show you something and
he pulled out this dusty old rock
tumbler it was a motor and a coffee can
and a little
you know band between them and he said
come on with me we went out to the back
and we got some just some rocks some
regular old
ugly rocks and we put them in the can
with a little bit of
liquid and a little bit of of grit
powder and we closed the can up and he
turned this motor on he said come back
tomorrow and his can was making a you
know
racket as the stones went around and i
came back the next day
and we took we opened the can and we
took out
these amazingly beautiful polished rocks
[Music]
the same common stones that had gone in
through rubbing against each other like
this creating a little bit of friction
creating a little bit of noise had come
out these beautiful polished rocks
and that's always been in my mind my
metaphor
for a team working really hard on
something they're passionate about is
is that it's through the team through
that group of incredibly talented people
bumping up against each other having
arguments having fights sometimes making
some noise
and working together they polish each
other
and they polish the ideas and what comes
out are these really beautiful
stones so
it's hard to explain and it's certainly
not the result of one person
i mean people like symbols so i'm the
symbol of certain things but
it really is it was a team effort on the
mac now
in my life i observed something fairly
early on
at apple
which i didn't know how to explain it
then but i've thought a lot about it
since
if you most things in life the dynamic
range between
average and the best is at most two to
one
right like if you go to new york city
and you get an average taxi cab driver
versus the best taxi cab driver
you know you're probably gonna get to
your destination with the best taxi cab
maybe
[Music]
30 percent faster you know in an
automobile what's the difference between
an average and the best maybe on
20 percent uh the best cd player in an
average cd player i know
20 percent so two to one is a big big
dynamic range in most of life
um in software
and it used to be the case in hardware
too the difference between average and
the best
is fifty to one maybe a hundred to one
easy okay i've very few things in life
are like this
but what i was lucky enough to spend my
life in
is like this and so i've
built a lot of my success
off finding these truly gifted people
and not settling for b and c players but
really going for the a
players and i found something i found
that when you get
enough a players together when you go to
through the incredible work to find you
know five of these eight players
they really like working with each other
because they they've never had a chance
to do that before
and they don't want to work with b and c
players
and so it becomes self-policing and they
only want to hire more a players
and so you build up these pockets of a
players and it propagates
and that's what the mac team was like
they were all a players and
these were extraordinarily talented
people the way to make movies is to do
stuff that you love because
you know for 25 years i worked on the
oprah show
and uh stephen will tell you that there
were day nights that i came home and i
almost you know it's hard to even like
take off my clothes because i knew i was
going to
be getting up four hours later but i
never really felt
exhausted like deplet never i felt
exhausted but i never felt depleted
so do the work that comes straight from
the soul of you from your background
from stories that you've grown up with
from stories that
bring you passion from stories that you
not just yearn to tell but that if you
don't tell them they won't get told
and when you when you are operating you
know the single
the single greatest uh wisdom
i think i've ever received other than
when people show you they are
is that the key to fulfillment
success happiness contentment
in life is when you align
your personality with what your soul
actually came to do i believe everybody
has a soul and has
you know their own personal spiritual
energy
so when you can use your personality to
serve
whatever that thing is you
can't help but be successful so if you
do films that come from the interior of
your soul
you do work you do art that comes from
the interior of you
it you cannot miss it's only when you're
doing stuff that you think might make
money
you think it may be a hit
or you think it may bring you some level
of attention or success
that isn't what does it i would have to
say that all of the great
wonderful experiences of my life that
have brought me to this moment
have come from working from the interior
of myself
and so that's why it feels so authentic
because it
it actually is so when you do that
you'll win
you sometimes like to take on a more
hands-on role with the companies that
you work
with or is that normal of an investor or
a vc to do
i think it's probably atypical um i mean
that's sort of why we've constructed the
space that we've constructed
which is to have a lot of these really
interesting companies here very early on
and what it allows me to do is sort of
transfer knowledge i mean look
right now i've come out of sort of like
you know
12 years of operating some of the most
interesting consumer businesses that
have been built on the internet
and i've been a part of now three
massively seminal
interesting products um winamp
aim and icq facebook um and so there's a
body of knowledge there that's
really relevant but it's only relevant
for a short period of time
four years from now i'll be as dumb as
any other vc but in these next three or
four years i probably have some
reasonable
knowledge to transfer and so the best
thing that i can do is make sure i'm in
a position to get that into as many
people as possible
because then at that point what i'm
hoping is then i'll be able to learn
from them
right because they'll really understand
the rules of how the next 10 years will
evolve
and then i'll be able to learn from them
and they'll feel
you know a sense of um not necessarily
obligation but like
you know that maybe hopefully a little
bit of you know gratitude
combined with a little bit of um um you
know pity
and then they'll want to sort of you
know teach me i very frequently get the
question
what's going to change in the next 10
years and
that is an interesting question it's a
very common one i almost
never get the question what's not going
to change
in the next 10 years and i submit to you
that that second
question is actually the more important
of the two
because you can build a business
strategy
around the things that are stable in
time and so as you pointed out in our
retail business
we know that customers want low prices
and i know that's going to be true 10
years from now they want fast delivery
they want vast selection it's impossible
to imagine a future 10 years from now
where a customer comes up to me and says
jeff i love amazon i just wish the
prices were a little higher
you know how you i love amazon i just
wish you delivered a little more slowly
impossible and so the effort that we put
into those
things spinning those things up
we know the energy we put into it today
we'll still be paying dividends for our
customers 10 years from now
and so those when you have something
that you know is true
even over the long term you can afford
to put a lot of energy into it
on aws the big ideas
are also pretty straightforward it's
impossible for me to imagine
that 10 years from now somebody is going
to say i love aws
i just wish it were a little less
reliable
or i love aws i just wish you would
raise
prices it should be a little more
expensive
or i love aws and i wish you would
innovate and improve the apis at a
slightly slower rate
none of those things you can imagine and
so
the big ideas in business are often
very obvious but it's very hard to
maintain a firm grasp of the obvious at
all times
but if you can do that and continue to
spin up those flywheels and put
energy into those things as we're doing
with aws
over time you build a better and better
service for your customers
on the things that genuinely matter to
them when
instead of just holding on to all of the
stock that you got from yahoo you did
what
we call a collar you collared so
you hedged it so tell everybody what
went through your mind because that was
a
big bet with huge dollars right and it
was a pr
it was actually pretty simple so you
know hedging stock if
you know yahoo paid us in yahoo stock
and you know i was smart enough to
recognize i guess
that what goes up could go down but it
wasn't that big a step because
i was worth more than a billion dollars
how much did i need right
so i was telling everybody just find me
a way to hedge it
so in the event look if the stock price
goes up and i leave something on the
table
so be it right but i like that being
next to my name and i wanted to keep it
and so
i sold calls bought puts and effectively
hedged it so that
by the time so there was a period of
time from when i'd done that
and the internet stock market kept on
going up and and i told people i'd
hedged it and goldman sachs the company
had
told people what i'd done and i remember
going on cnbc the business channel
and then the guy going boy don't you
feel stupid that yahoo stock has kept on
going up and you had this hedge
and i'm like yeah i feel so stupid
riding around my g5 that i bought online
you know and and it was just like not to
sound like a crazy greasy greedy
capitalist but
yeah and it was like i just don't want
to screw it up
and so i hedged it and then the internet
bubble burst
and i was fully protected and actually
even made a little bit more money and
you know middle um you know the motto
that the
you know what i learned was you just you
don't need to be greedy
you know i was very very blessed i was
very fortunate look i didn't plan the
internet stock market to go up and i
didn't plan to go down so i was lucky in
terms of scale
and i didn't want to screw it up and so
i hedged
do you remember how much your first
server cost you said oh yeah no
eighty-five dollars
eighty-five dollars yeah no i and i
remember that because um that was the
gating factor for us launching new
schools i
i mean we had this philosophy from the
very beginning that we didn't wanna be
this project it wasn't even a company at
the very beginning but we didn't want to
be burning a lot of money right we
weren't planning on raising a lot of
money we didn't want to be
one of these things that raised a bunch
of money and you know was losing a bunch
of money and then decided that we'd
somehow pull it through at the end and
um so you know so 85 for the first
server put ads on the site and
the the ads at the beginning were uh we
just were running some kind of ad
network and
you remember what the first ad was um no
i don't um i don't know how did you get
ads
um this was eduardo's job was i mean
with your ad sales
yeah he basically like he was
responsible for making sure that we had
enough money to keep things running in
the beginning
and um you know but basically i mean so
it was the server was 85
and you know dustin and i basically
worked on kind of efficiency and making
sure that we can fit more schools onto
each server
um and um and eduardo worked on selling
more ads or making a deal so that we can
get
an ad network so that way we can we can
make more money but then whenever we had
more money we rented another 85
a month server and we kind of went from
there and um
i don't know just it's just an
interesting way of seeing you never
spent money you didn't have in the
beginning
not in the beginning no and then i mean
even that was the constraint on your
growth rate how many new 85 dollars is
you could get
yeah and i mean it was actually good
because i i mean you know sometimes it's
really nice to have the time to
get your product to be awesome and deal
with scaling problems and one of the
things that was interesting was um
you know at the time i don't know how
many people remember this but i mean
friendster was the service that had
massive scaling problems
yeah you know the idea was they were
they grew quickly and it was really hard
for them to scale and
um you know the fact that we could kind
of go college by college and
and kind of optimize the service and
make it more efficient and offer new
features but make sure that they worked
um i think was really key i mean we're
talking about people who'd never built a
company before we'd never built any
large-scale software
or anything so having that period where
we could just bake it
and you know people these days like to
talk about how these services grow super
quickly
and facebook did grow quickly but i
think it took a year for us to get a
million users and we thought that that
was incredibly fast but
um and and i think it is but it wasn't
as quick as a lot of things grow today
and i think actually having that time
to bake it was really valuable for us
many times i've gone with what i thought
was fact and sometimes
i thought were pretty good hunches and i
didn't do so well
but i'm very fortunate that more than 50
of the time i did do very very well
and i'm finding out more recently in my
life the last couple years
that you try not to just think with your
brain but think with your heart
how do you feel about the situation how
do you feel about the people
no matter how kind they are and i've had
some really nice people
uh got in foreign countries and
everything else that were the nicest
people in the world
turned out to be total rip-offs but i
didn't know that
there were clues along the way so i say
to everybody and i say to myself now
feel the person out or feel the
situation
with your heart what is your instinct i
think now more in life that
i go off instinct plus facts you
obviously have to have some facts along
with it
does it become easier the more you do it
yep much easier
when you're when you're set to well how
do i feel about this
shall we say with data stable data that
i have how do i feel about these facts
and then and how i feel about it just my
intuition how do i feel about it from my
heart
yeah and the more you think about doing
it that way the more it happens
i know what i can do now once you know
what you can do then you can do it a
second time
and that's why so many people can go
bankrupt and then come
come right back because they know now
the first time you do it you don't know
the second time you do it you're like
i think maybe the third and fourth time
you're like i know for sure i can do
this
so that's why i say success is so
important success is my duty
responsibility and obligation to myself
forget my family for a second
i need success for me to feel good about
me so i can be good with my family
and um i think a lot of people are
trying to do their life without having
success be part of it success is part of
my mental
like i think i think success actually is
the best medication for my mental health
from 15 to 25 i was using drugs every
day
so when i tell you hey you can do
anything
i was a habitual
daily drug user overdosed three times
was brought back by people just
wandering into a room saying oh this
guy's in trouble
okay i was i don't know if i was trying
to kill myself at the time or i was just
didn't know what i was doing or stupid
or whatever like
i was a walking time bomb and i was not
to be trusted by my family by my friends
there was no one in my life between 15
and 25
that i could have a positive influence
on i was a liability
to everyone in my life including my
family
and my friends and people i went to
school with and the places i worked at i
lost seven jobs in a row
i was unemployable 25 i went to a
treatment center and said i got to turn
this around
i got to turn this around i cannot keep
using drugs they're bad for me i
make poor decisions when i'm using them
i i i go out with the wrong people hang
with the wrong people
end up in the wrong fights i literally
got like when you're using drugs you're
going to pick fights you can't win
not in a lifetime you're going to get
the wrong cars
make the wrong decisions the wrong
purchases and you're going to miss a lot
of great opportunities
so first thing is you can't do great
things
if you're incapable of making great
decisions and when you're
under the influence and i don't want to
preach to you i'm just telling you what
what advice i'd give myself if i was
on the comeback and i was 15 years old
and being influenced by everybody
smoking the kush
it's cool now
it's probably going to be legal
everywhere
going out drinking on the weekends
forgetting everything
that you did and
just making poor decisions so i tell you
hey you got you got to figure out how
how is that going to somehow advance
your life you're going to have to make
some hard choices if i'm a young guy
coming up young gal coming up
how can i pick great relationships when
everybody's under the influence
and again i don't mean to sound like a
like a a preacher or anything because
i'm definitely not that we're going to
have a great time this weekend
i'm here for a week we're going to have
a lot of fun but i couldn't do that if i
was still
under the influence every day you had a
kind of a tough start in life there was
kind of drugs there was job losses a lot
of kind of
things happened to you what was that
trigger that made you say enough was
enough i want to turn this around
yeah well there was you know i i was
i just hated my life man i hated my life
i hated
that i was a disappointment to myself my
family
my community i knew it
they knew it um
look at myself in the mirror i was
praying meditating begging like
like um and and i just kept making the
wrong moves
like so at some point
you know when you when you try when you
try and you don't quit enough times
sooner or later it's going to click when
you lose a job and i've lost a bunch of
jobs
when you lose a job the the truth is
people need to confront
get to full acceptance that
and understand that once you lose a job
you act you might not be an engineer or
an accountant anymore
but you have a new job immediately yeah
and the new job
is to get a job right and and when that
guy heard those videos i get he he
watched three of the 12 videos
and he basically i showed him hey look
you're not out of work your new work is
to get a job
and you need to go get a job now you can
go get an unemployment check if you want
to
but sooner or later you're going to have
to confront the beast and the beast is
uh i i have this gorilla under my back
wall it reminds me
confront the beast bro okay you got to
confront the biggest
the biggest uh beast in the jungle and
and i'm the enemy in my life
i am the biggest problem i have and so
uh when you lose a job first thing you
got to confront is you
and say wait a minute am i out of work
oh no i just lost my title as engineer
my new job is to get a job and commit to
going to get that job
and because people it's going to be
easier to get a job this week than it
will be
26 weeks from now i promise you
because 26 weeks from now you're going
to have 25 million people
running back to the job market you want
to go look when they're not looking
keep take care of yourself every day you
got to do the work
some things you cannot delegate taking
care of your body
food you eat somebody can cook it for
you you still got to put it in
and then you got to take care of
yourself and then you got to take your
ideas and your dreams
only you know what they really are and
only you
and you alone know what your real
potential is
your wife can't do that for you your
husband can't your boss can't your
manager can't
god's not going to even do it for you
folks you got to do that
you want to be in good shape you can
pray for all you want
you want to get your money right you can
pray for it but you got to do the work
your destiny is waiting for you but you
got to do the work
the way i lead is i go do stuff
first time and when i talk about doing
stuff i'm talking about i move the bar
the only thing i look at every day is
did i move the graph up
i'm just uh like
i love that the the symbol of hercules i
think it was hercules holding the world
yeah and and i imagine if he if it was a
live character he'd be pushing it up
more
all the time that that's what i when i
see a graph i look at
we graph everything right i look grass
and i'm like i want to go be hercules
i want to lift it and that's all my
people see me doing every day
i don't i'm not an organizer i'm not a
planner
i'm not the meeting guy um
i'm the i'm i'm i'm hurt i move the i'm
hercules
constantly moving that bar moving the
bar moving the bar i'm i'm the one
making the points
right and so i'm like look i don't steve
i'm going to make 40 points today
put 20 on the board dawg i don't need
you to do because you can't steve you
can't make it
okay right uh so
me and ryan i'm like right right i'm a
race i'm gonna raise two million dollars
today
i bet you can't even do half of what i
do
and what happens is you know they see
my energy is toward activities that get
results
not not not ideas or concepts you guys
got to get hard
you need to get hard okay it doesn't
mean you need to be
mean i was telling this guy this morning
he's running a company he's got 14
people he's like
man you know he's like every time i come
to you come here i
i see the way your people look at you i
see the way your people respect you how
do you do that i said dude i'm hard
people don't respect soft in fact they
resent
softness they resent being in soft
environments
they start showing up late they leave
early the softer the environment gets
the less
dangerous the environment is the softer
the environment is and the less happy
they are i'm telling you when people get
hard
people get happy people are happier
in dangerous environments than they are
in soft environments
everybody's going to lose something dude
i've lost dogs i lost my older brother
you you're not if if the reason you're
going to become a drug addict because
you lost your daddy
which man everybody should be a drug
addict everybody that never connected
i'm like wait
oh you were abandoned by your father he
abandoned you i'm like he died
heart blew up in his chest yeah okay so
i'm like what what is the
problem here the reason i got on drugs
broke was because i was
bored you're bored i would have taken
anything
you could offer me homosexuality yeah
let's roll i'm in
uh you could have offered me a a
marathon
yeah i'll do i'll run a marathon you
could have offered me
anything that would have been
interesting right i would have
i would have taken it i was looking for
leadership man i was looking for
activity i was looking for
aggression yeah what could i do you know
it's interesting mcgregor he talks about
he's like look i don't win because of my
skills i win because i'm obsessed
and so i took out of that treatment
center um
they introduced me to other drugs by the
way they they wanted me to take this
these other uh adderall or phenobarbital
or something did you take those or
no i brought them home with me and threw
them away and said you know what my new
drug is gonna become
success i made a commitment when i was a
25 years old and broke okay
i came up with a new plan first thing i
did was this
okay i made a plan so i could
retire rich actually with me you could
just drop the retire thing because once
you start making money you're like
i don't want to retire i just want to
make money man
okay no but most people don't like money
because they never have enough man to
have any fun with it
right or they make a little bit of money
and they blow it
and then the next thing you know they're
out of work and they're like oh i hate
money because the last time i had money
i blew it all
i went to strip joints i bought a
ferrari erected
i got in trouble next you see what i'm
saying michael tyson probably doesn't
really like money because every time he
got in he
it he screwed it up but but for those of
you
you need a get rich plan
you need to get rich plan you don't need
to get by plan right now you got to get
my plan i want to get rich plan
so you need to understand what that
takes and the first thing it takes on
the get rich plan
is income you got to increase your
income if you make
if you make if you got a job making 36
grand a year you got to wake up and say
you will never
ever ever ever have anything if you keep
that job at 36 grand a year by the way
the job is not the problem it's the 36
that is the problem okay so you got to
figure out dude how do i get from 36 to
360.
oh my god that's going to be hard not
really if you take a look
first of all look at your commitment
okay man i'm a waitress
okay good there's other waitresses that
are making 360 grand a year
you have to first make the decision i
know this sounds esoteric
nothing happens without
the decision
to get rich and understand the plan you
have doesn't work
okay because the plan your mom and dad
had was never a decision to get rich
it was to get by right that's why they
said diversify that's why they said buy
a house remember the house that was one
of the plans
a house does not make you rich it's
impossible
it ties you down there's no income
associated with it okay
so every decision has got to be this i
got to get this number up to that
that's why i don't buy a house because
me buying a house doesn't give me 360 a
year
you get it or 3 million a year right
what gets me that is income
in the treatment centers you know you
you basically share
all your secrets i always tell them like
i want to be rich i want to be famous i
want to write books and the guy's like
dude if you don't give up on all that
you will be back here in 30 days
he's like you need to be satisfied i
never forget the speech on the 28th day
health insurance had run out so they're
going to kick my ass
out right because the money ran up he
says if you don't give up on all these
ideas these these
grand grand illusions and the
grandiosity you don't give up on all
that
you will be hated and i threw all that
addiction and
obsession with destruction that you you
like understand as well as anyone and
have talked about so eloquently
i threw all that obsessive energy into
work
to become a master at a few things
and and that's what's really changed my
life my direction to where i can just
run down a path
and and over the period of 35 years
create something for myself that
you know i'm sitting in a room with
makes you obsessed they're gonna tell
you
like they told me and i believed it for
a while i did but i didn't
it's look you're a drug addict you can't
help it you're powerless
it's in your genetic code and you have
no control over it
now i'm going to tell you right now that
i believe that to be complete
complete garbage in [ __ ] so
if i was a drug addict and it's
completely out of my control
then i would have had to use drugs today
yeah and i didn't
so using drugs is a choice yeah i would
tell you
and i would tell everybody that that has
that addictive
nature is congratulate yourself and pat
yourself on the pack
that you have the ability to be addicted
to something
and take that addiction dude and put it
into something unbelievable
because every every super successful
person
that i have studied and or met is
has the ability to be obsessed with
something to the point of losing sleep
to the point of i don't need to need to
eat
uh i'll go in debt i'll go bankrupt i'll
go
down with the ship to make this thing
happen and that's really what turned my
whole life around was
just flipping the addiction not trying
to not be in control not trying to turn
it all over
just saying hey i'm gonna take this
energy and i'm gonna dump it into
into work when you're hating on somebody
in your same space
right or they're hating on you remember
this you keep focused on creating
massive massive success
okay because when you get up to the top
of the food chain whatever the food
chain is in your space whether it's
financial or
insurance or real estate or influencers
or podcasters
or or maybe you're doing a real business
you're not doing it you're not an
influencer and you're not a podcaster
you're like
why all these guys spending all this
time doing podcasts i got a business to
grow i got employees
maybe you're doing that
so what's my point
anytime you watch any of my videos you
say dude what's the guy really talking
about
i'm doing this for you i don't get paid
to do it
so if you're getting any value out of
this i'm telling you when you get up the
food chain and you will because you're
watching it
you will get up the food chain you will
become a super successful person
but you won't if you hate
you will not become super successful
if you take the time to worry about
these other people in your space
flowing power man love on them
send them love send them customers send
them deals but don't be surprised
when they don't send it back because
they're not
no book tells you this
all these guys doing their little quotes
talking about abundancy
scarcity but watch how they act when you
get up there man watch it man it's gonna
be crazy you're gonna be like cardone
told me
while i was eating snow the dude told me
that they were gonna hate on me i had i
had somebody call me the other day and
said hey dude i want to give you some
you need you need to know how to handle
some of these situations you're running
up against
okay because there's a way for you to
prevent some of this some of this these
people hating on you i said dude i don't
i'm not going to try to prevent somebody
from being stupid
that's just dumb i got enough insurance
in my life already
most of the time the accident never
happens the way to ensure
that these haters and criticizers and
little thinkers don't bother you is
don't be them
number one number two keep following
them love and power baby
number three number three number three
get to the top
get to the top of the food chain
where everybody at the top knows you and
the people that wouldn't flow you on the
way up
or wish they didn't do what they did
okay if your life is not the way it
should be then you should
hate yourself right now i don't blame
you you should the best way
but dude i i hated my before i loved my
i hated myself so bad i couldn't look in
the mirror
jared told me the other day he's like
you don't have a mirror in your bathroom
i can bring you in there right now
there's no mirror in there check this
out i said dude i don't need a mirror i
remember you know what that bathroom i
remember having an apartment where i
couldn't put a mirror
on the wall broke it i broke the mirror
look at that right there there no mirror
i told the chair yesterday i said dude
i don't have a mirror i said i i don't
care i don't need to look at myself
i remember when i look at myself and i
hated myself
broke the mirror out of my bathroom
because i couldn't look at my face
because the mirror reminded me every
time i had a mirror i was putting
something on it
to put it in my face hated myself
man hated myself didn't have any money
had all this potential
overdosing daily you guys want a man you
want to change you got a bunch of
potential tell you tell yourself the
truth
okay do you have more potential than
you're using
ask yourself right now just ask yourself
just meditate on this a second
do i have more potential than i'm using
do you guys ask yourself that [ __ ] every
morning when you wake up man what do you
say to yourself in the morning first
thing i do in the morning i wake up say
do i have more potential thank you alex
do i have more potential than i'm using
dude if i do
if it's even this much then i gotta get
the [ __ ] up
and go get it this is where god lives
dude this is the spiritual part of life
is the seeking of potential
not the seeking of sin of serenity
and happiness serenity and happiness are
[ __ ] selfish
commodities it's about me man for me to
seek my potential the next level
means i got to give up what i have
that's where god lives man
god's proud of grant cardone you know
what a bunch of humans don't like grant
god loves grant yo you know what because
god's like dude that guy
he will put it out there you guys all
praying you know what my prayer is my
prayer is not talking to god my prayer
is taking action
now i've got some special bonus clips
that i think you're gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the
billionaire mindset
question of the day i want to know what
was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and your plan of action
for the next week also if you've already
got your billionaire mindset companion
pdf calendar
get ready for another amazing video
tomorrow or if you don't have
it yet you can get it for free in the
first line of the description below and
if you're enjoying this billionaire
mindset series give me a hashtag
billionairemindset in the comments below
so i can celebrate you
finding your passion does not have to be
hard understanding what you should be
doing with your life and how you can be
serving other people
is one of the greatest gifts you can
give not just yourself
but your family your community the world
around you but if you write it off
if you write off finding your passion as
being too difficult
not worthwhile too expensive too scary
that you can't do it then you cheat
yourself up that amazing gift and you
will never be happy
we're gonna fix that in this video so i
wrote this book built to serve
and i did it because i was on my tour
last year
when i hit 90 days 23 different cities
and i went for a different reason i went
on my tour
talking about how to build momentum in
your life in your business and what i
kept coming back with
in every city was how do i find my
passion how do i find my purpose i don't
know what i'm supposed to do with my
life
in every city the same thing kept
happening over and over and over and
over and over again and so i don't think
the right thing to do is slam people for
asking the question
of how do i find my passion i think the
better answer is to actually give them a
process
to give people a solution and it just
blew my mind how difficult people make
it on themselves
and they feel like they need to meditate
for years need to hire some super
expensive coach
they feel like it's hopeless and they'll
never figure it out because they look at
the people around them and you see well
the people around you haven't figured it
out so how am i going to figure it out
and if your parents haven't figured it
out
why are you listening to them to help
you figure out your purpose and your
passion what you're supposed to do
it doesn't have to be that difficult and
i started going through this process
with people when i met them
at my different groups and my speaking
gigs in each of the cities that i went
to
and the most memorable one was in san
jose
where i walk people through this process
of who i how and
just the first question was like hey i
don't know i don't know what to do with
my life i don't know how to find my
passion and then walk them through the
who i help process and then that person
started
crying in in uh in a in a great way of
like wow finally having some clarity
and then the rest of the q a basically
was me doing the same thing for the
people
who i have who i have who i have who i
have who i have
and and now people have clarity and
momentum where they didn't have it
before and so
it's why i wrote the book it's why i'm
making videos like this is because i
want to share
the process with you so that you can
find your clarity you can find your
passion
you can find your purpose and turn it
into something that builds a happy life
for you
aim for the people around you for the
rest of your life
it's one of the most important thing if
you figure this out understand
that this will never get old finding
your passion
finding your purpose those two things
will never get old you'll love doing
those things
for the rest of your life so i talked
about there's a three step process who
why how i'm gonna walk you through it
right now it starts with who so who
is your one word most important core
value when you figure this out it gives
you so much clarity
over who you are to allow you to make
better decisions moving forward
so my who is belief my most important
core value is belief
and understanding that allows me to be
around people who also believe
right if you're trying to get into a
relationship you're trying to hire
somebody for your team or you're trying
to manage somebody who's already on your
team
or you want to attract suppliers or
customers or investors
core value is the thing that keeps
people together and we talk about it a
lot in in
your corporate world and your list of 13
core values nobody live they don't even
know what those 13 core values are no
ceo
knows off by heart what their core
values are and that if you don't know
your core values are then you're not
living them
so forget the thirteen one what's your
single most important core value
mine is believe yours might be care or
freedom
or creativity or structure or
or discipline right i mean somebody who
values
security as their most important core
value versus somebody who values
creativity and freedom right those are
how you manage and interact with that
person can be very different
you can't push the person of our
security on freedom and creativity
right and somebody who values creativity
as their most important doesn't want to
be boxed in
by security and so when you understand
what your most important core value is
and so think about
what what movies you like the people
that you love the lessons that you
learned from your favorite teacher all
of this
or just spend some time thinking about
what is my most important core value
what the pick one over everything else
don't worry about being the perfect one
yet just you have to pick one this
exercise is in the book that walk you
through it in a lot more detail but
one core value understanding that gives
you clarity for the rest
that will never change i'm believe for
life if anything just more and more
believe
right step two is figuring out your why
your why is something simon preaches
right
start with why your why is your purpose
your purpose comes from your pain
this is this is what i think simon
missed in his in his
ted talk your purpose comes from your
pain your purpose
for the rest of your life is helping
people who currently are
what you used to be there's lots of
people who currently are
who you used to be whatever you
struggled with think about
the lowest moment as a human in your
life what was that what were you doing
what were you faced with
emotionally bankrupt like when was that
moment you felt worthless as a person
what was that moment what happened
there's lots of people who currently are
that and you going back and helping
them teaching them giving them hope
motivation guidance
is the thing that will lift you up for
the rest of your life
so again that gives you massive clarity
and then the how is the last step and
the how is how did you get out of the
hole
so i love helping entrepreneurs my why
is helping entrepreneurs because i
struggled so much as an entrepreneur why
am i still doing this how do i still
have energy
it's 20 years now of helping
entrepreneurs it's crazy
the youtube channel for 11 years why
why still go why still make so many
videos every day why have 12 different
channels
oh hurry this side why have why have all
these chat
why my why
propels me forward my purpose demands it
the how for me of getting out of that
hole that i was in
was modeling success i looked at bill
gates and how he started microsoft and i
learned those strategies and applied it
to my company
the how becomes your passion to be able
to teach people how to get out of it
teaching people how to get out of the
hole that they're in that you used to be
in
is your passion it's not that
challenging to figure out
how you execute it may change with years
right so
right now i'm doing youtube when i first
found this
youtube wasn't even around so i did
speeches and seminars and then that
became youtube and
and now then became books and in 20
years is going to be vr and some other
technology
awesome but that's something that will
serve me for life i'll be 95 years old
sitting in a
senior's home or in a wheelchair or
maybe by by that time we'll be advancing
technology i'll still be
you know running around but i'll be 95
years old and looking back and still
loving helping people
if you're an entrepreneur who needs
belief
who feels hopeless i'll still love
helping that person
get better and believe in themselves and
give them strategies and how they can
model success to go off and do it
and so this is the gift that i wanted
it's why i wrote the book
right if you don't have it yet you can
check it out there's probably a link
somewhere in the description below or
just go to karma.com or amazon you can
find it i want people to find their
purpose
i want people to find their passion it's
a much more fulfilling life for
you for your family for the people
around you and it's not that difficult
to process to go through
it frustrates me when people are making
it seem a lot more complex than it has
to be
and when you get that clarity for your
life for the rest of your life
i think it's the most valuable gift that
you can give to yourself and the people
around you
finding your calling is easy i think
it's crazy that people don't know how to
find their calling up
i think it's among the most important
questions that you need to figure out
in life like how are you living your
life without knowing
why you're here what your calling is how
you're going to serve the message you
have the one
impact that you want to have it's crazy
you can't
live a happy fulfilled life until you
know what that is
and it's not that difficult and it just
blows my mind because
when you figure it out when will smith
figures it out
when all these super insanely talented
people
figured out the world's gonna change can
you imagine
a world where everybody has found their
calling
and is living it i want to live in that
world
and so that's why i'm trying to create
that world here's how you do it
it's actually not that difficult it's in
my new book built to serve link in the
description go get it
this is the overview one it starts with
understanding that you're built to serve
right there's a reason why i called the
book built to serve you are built to
serve
your calling comes from helping other
people
it's not to make just a ton of money
it's not just to
be able to say hey here i am on the
beach right that's not your calling
doesn't make you happy those are
short-lived moments your calling comes
from serving and helping other people
you are built
to serve your happiness will come from
helping other people
because you are built to serve three
steps to figure it out
one your who your one word most
important core value mine is believe
what is yours
look through all the things that you
love that's made you come alive
your favorite movie your favorite book
what you love about your parents
look to who your favorite teacher was of
all time why it's not because
mrs jones taught you great eight math
it's because she made you feel a certain
way what
what did she make you feel why right
make that connective tissue between all
the things that make you come alive
and then it makes it easy for you to
figure out what you love more than
anything else what your single most
important core value is
mine is belief thus everything i make is
our own belief
the people in my life the content i make
the products that i create all of it
has to be around belief this video the
intention is belief i want you to
believe in yourself more
maybe i don't achieve it but it's my
intention every single time
and so when you figure out your most
important core value and then you start
to organize your life and your business
around it it has a gigantic impact on
your life and what you do how you feel
if i was around people all day long who
didn't believe
that'd be a really toxic negative hard
place for me to win in
but since i know that i'm about believe
i attract people who also love the
message and believe it's why we have
such an amazing community
it's why all the videos i put up are
positive i'm not putting up videos
trashing somebody showing them at their
worst
their weakest moments why they suck
those videos would probably get more
views to be honest
but i don't because it's not about
belief same thing for you what is your
single most important core value
so look for all the things you love and
then try to draw a line write down three
descriptive keywords
so what you loved about your parents
what you loved about your favorite
teacher what you loved about your
favorite movie
your favorite book all of it three
descriptive keywords for each
and then see which word pops up over and
over and over and over again
that's your one word most important core
value you have to figure it out
that will never get old i'm going to
believe in people for life next
you're why it's who i have your why your
purpose comes from your pain
the thing that you struggled the most
with as a human you felt the most
worthless
most insecure most disposable as a
person
that thing you want to help other people
not suffer as much as you did
so will smith trying to figure out his
calling it's not that hard
go back and find the single moment where
you felt the most worthless
most disposable lowest as a human
what was that moment your purpose in
life is to help other people
not feel that way as well i was meeting
a woman a couple days ago on the beach
and she she was saying i felt so many
times where i felt low
there's no just one moment so many times
they're going to be great talk to me
about them
and one of them was an ex-partner
leaving her
or her best friend one of them was her
father
not treating her well and having some
abuse in the family it's like okay great
let's just take those two what's common
between those two
different moments in your life different
people around you
what's common and she took five seconds
to think about it then said
i felt disposable and then she had this
pause and then she came up and hugged me
like every moment that i felt the lowest
in my life i felt disposable by other
people
that's your why that's your purpose
to help other people not feel disposable
and you'll love that for life then she
got all emotional thank me
it's not that difficult draw a line if
there's not just one moment draw a line
between all of the negative things that
you felt the worst as a human
maybe other people didn't care about it
but you did when you go home and you
felt worthless why what happened what's
the common feeling between them
your your purpose for the rest of your
life is to help other people not feel
the same way
that's your calling and that will never
get old that's the who that's the why
then the how
how you got out of it how you suffered
through it what you did the techniques
is teachable it's a recipe and show
other people how to do it too
you're still on your path you're not
done growing you're not done learning
you never want to be
i'm not done growing learning will smith
has not done
learning growing you're never done you
don't want to be but you know more than
you did five years ago and there's lots
of people who currently are
what you were five years ago they
currently are they're living in the hell
that you experienced
they're right there and they feel
hopeless and feel there's no path
there's no exit there's no plan they
don't know what to do they're lost
you represent hope and you can touch
them in a way that nobody else can you
can touch them in a way that i can't
that will smith can't because you've
been through it where i haven't and will
smith hasn't either you've been through
it
and so how you got out of it is
inspiration and it's a recipe you could
teach because most people
who went through what you went through
don't get out of it
they still are stuck for years or
decades they're stuck
so it's the who the why and the hap
find your purpose find your calling
be set for life on a purposeful
happy fulfilled life
that's the path and i hope you follow it
you don't win a nobel prize by telling
yourself that you want to win a nobel
prize
you win a nobel prize by having a
mission so big that it forces you to
become
somebody new a stronger more bold more
resilient version
of you if you make success your goal you
will most likely miss it because you
have the wrong
outcome in mind make impact your goal
make your mission your goal and you'll
end up having more success than you ever
thought possible i look at my youtube
channel as an example and
the next goal would be to have 10
million subscribers right
i got my 100 000 plaque i got three of
them there
i got my million plaque the next goal is
10 million
and there's nothing wrong with having
goals but the problem is if i made 10
million
the thing like all i'm doing is chasing
down 10 million subscribers
it forces you to do short term decisions
that
end up not serving you right if i wanted
to just blow up my channel
the best way to do it isn't actually to
spread positive content
negativity spreads much faster than
positivity if i made a top 10 video on
why this person sucked or an espresso
about how this person's an idiot
or people fighting people can't help but
see that people
that's why people stop to see the car
accident on the highway
right we don't reward the good drivers
you want to see the chaos you want to
see what caused the flame
there's a fight on the street corner you
stop to see what's going on
right we're attracted to the negativity
more than the positivity that's a faster
way to blow up my channel
the problem is i wouldn't feel good
about it
i don't want to spread negativity i
don't want to spread conflict and chaos
i don't want to spread pessimism i don't
want to spread despair
i don't want to spread ego i don't want
to spend negativity i just i don't want
to do that
and so it would lead to me flaming out
before i ever hit the goal
that's the problem you can have this
goal this is what most people do
you have some goal here's my goal i'm
going to do whatever it takes to get to
that goal
the problem is you won't do whatever it
takes because it's going to get too hard
you can only
do things for so long that you don't
love before you quit and give up
and so there's nothing wrong with having
a goal but more important than the goal
is the mission
i want to sell the world's biggest
problem it's something that's never
going to happen
never in my lifetime it's never gonna
happen i want people to believe in
themselves more
it's never gonna hit that ultimate goal
where everybody is michael jordan at
something it will never happen
and i wake up every day trying to do
that and so if you make a goal
tied to some outcome like getting 10
million subscribers on youtube
it's going to force you down a path that
likely won't serve you so you lead with
the mission
you leave with the impact and success
will follow
now how do you do it i'm going to give
you a three-step process that i think
will help step number one is understand
that your purpose
comes from your pain so the goal isn't
the thing the mission the impact is the
thing great so what's your mission well
your mission comes from your pain your
purpose comes from your pain the thing
that you struggled the most with in life
is the thing that you want to help other
people with
for life there are so many people who
currently are what you used to be
think about who you used to be whether
it's a year ago five years ago 10 years
ago
when were you at the lowest of lows the
lowest of those you felt worthless
hopeless
there was no path forward you didn't
know what to do you were lost
maybe you turned to the dark side of
life for a little bit
that person there's a lot of people who
currently are that person
you can help them you must help them you
want to help them that's your purpose
that's your mission
for the rest of your life so people
struggle with figuring out what's my
purpose that's it it's not that hard
it's not that hard you want to help
people who currently are
who you used to be and every time you
step up and you keep learning you keep
growing
you reach back and you help people learn
and grow a little bit more as well your
purpose comes from your pain
that's your mission for life step number
two is have your big wine little y your
big why
is your big mission the why what you're
doing right your purpose from your pain
what
what you're trying to do i wake up every
day and i'm trying to conquer this
impossible thing that's your big why
and sometimes that's motivating
inspiring it gets you out of bed you
want to go do it it
it gets you feeling amazing but
sometimes it feels too big
sometimes it feels impossible sometimes
you question yourself like who are you
to go off and do this crazy big thing
that's where the little why comes into
place the little why
is you saying well i may not be able to
do this big thing but i can help one
person
and it's thinking back the one person
that you helped one youtube comment that
came in
one client who took your advice one
person who you met on the street and you
helped or somebody who showed up to your
event or a client
customer who called in and you help them
you help them you help them you've
helped somebody
and even though you may feel like
helping a billion people is way too
impossible
you know you can help somebody and so on
the days when you need that little bit
extra motivation on days when you feel
too small
you remember your little why that you
can still get up and you can help one
person and another person and another
person
and so in the days when the big wise
enough amazing and when it's not enough
you turn the little y
you have the big y and the little y
those combined help give the motivation
to get going every single day
and then step three is have daily
momentum the biggest thing for most
people that's missing is momentum
you're a genius you have great ideas you
could do amazing things
i believe in you i see it across all the
people that i've met off the tour i did
last year the tour i'm doing next year
you have amazing genius level talent the
problem for so many entrepreneurs is
they start and they stop and they start
and they stop they don't see results and
so they quit
that starting stopping is the thing that
prevents you from winning it's the daily
consistent
grind every single day doing something
to move your mission forward
that's important my channel has won even
though
i'm less talented than a lot of people
who i've passed because i did a video
every day
and and it's been you know it was three
videos a day and now we're doing six
videos a day across
youtube across different channels it's
crazy it's crazy it's just being willing
to get up and every day do it
right just if you're trying to if you're
trying to lose weight
if you diet once a week if you eat
healthy once a week
if you exercise once a week you're not
going to get results why do you think
you're going to get results in your
business
it's the same thing it's consistency
it's the every single day
follow-through and it's hard to
anticipate what you can do in a day
but if you keep looking back if you did
something every day for the next six
months you look back you'll see how far
you came like i can't believe i came
that far it was only six months ago
that's wild
that's crazy because every single day
you did work the only thing you're
missing is momentum so let's start with
this
purpose is not passion they're related
but they're not the same thing passion
is also not that hard to figure out
neither is purpose people just have not
been given the right tools
so let's simplify it for you today and
if you're someone who's struggling to
figure out what your purpose and your
passion are
this video is going to be insanely
helpful for you i have a who why how
process
who is your most important core value
we're not going to dive into that in
this video
but the next two are your why and your
how your why is your purpose and your
how is your passion
so let's start with purpose your purpose
is your why your purpose comes from your
pain your purpose
is whatever the thing you struggled with
the most in life think back to the most
painful moment
in your life what was it what was
happening what was around you what was
that moment
for for positive entrepreneur optimistic
people this actually might be a
challenge for me it was a challenge
because
i don't want to think about the bad past
i don't think about
what happened to me i'm focused on what
i'm doing now and going forward not
not rear view mirror stuff what happened
back then doesn't matter except it does
because the thing that will fill you up
the most is helping people who are
currently going through the thing that
you struggled with the most
so whatever was the most painful moment
in your life
from when you're born until right now
that you can remember not physical pain
psychological pain mental pain the thing
that made you feel terrible
what was that thing your purpose
is to help other people who are feeling
that right now
and so imagine who you are now and
imagine who you used to be whether
that's a year ago five years ago 10
years ago
go back to whoever that person was let's
just say it's five years ago
great the person you are now can help
the person who you were five years ago
you may not have all the answers you're
still on your path you don't know
everything
but you've grown you've you've come out
of the hole you're better than you were
five years ago
talk to the person you were five years
ago helping that person
is your purpose you've climbed up the
staircase right you've you've grown
there's still
a lot more stairs to grow you don't want
the staircase to end
that staircase is your growth is your
professional personal development for
life you want to keep climbing
and every time you take a step what you
want to do is reach down
and help somebody else up but you can
only help people to the extent that
you've grown
if you've taken eight steps on the
staircase that's all you can help people
up to get to step number eight
if you get the 20 you can help people
more so we want to keep growing keep
climbing those stairs and then keep
reaching back and pulling people up and
giving them a hand that's your purpose
for life you'll you'll like serving
people and helping people
and it's tied to your core value your
who your one word we're not talking
about it much in this video
but you'll just like helping people
because service is hardwired into our
brain
helping people is hardwired to your
brain it has a similar impact on your
brain
as food and sex it's hardwired you'll
like it you want to help people you want
to serve
but who you serve will be different
it'll have a different impact i
love helping people in general but if
you're an entrepreneur that's something
extra special
there's so many great causes in the
world there's so many great causes
why this instead of this because you
have an emotional connection to it
an emotional attachment to it why
because you went through it
because you suffered through it and you
want to make sure that nobody else has
to suffer
as much as you suffered your purpose
comes from your pain
period it'll fill you up for life
helping entrepreneurs will fill me up
for the rest of my life
it will never get old when i'm tired
when i have no energy when i'm depleted
i will still meet with entrepreneurs
because it fills me up your purpose
comes from your pain
you have to find it now let's talk about
passion so your passion is your how your
passion is the things that you're doing
how you're going to actually execute
against your why execute against your
purpose what are you doing
it's great that you believe an
entrepreneur is amazing but what are you
going to do
how are you going to go about doing it
so for me
it's making videos for me it's doing
speaking gigs for me it's writing books
for me it's helping people one-on-one
for me it's doing
events right that's my how but that will
evolve that will change
right i started doing this helping
entrepreneur thing when i was 22 years
old
and that started just by doing speaking
and then then it became my website
and i had 100 000 plus pages of content
and then i shut the thing down overnight
and i focused on youtube and it's been a
10 year plus journey on youtube
and and maybe in 10 years that's gone
and i'm doing something totally
different
i don't know the how will change a lot
what you get passionate about or to
mel's point about energy what you get
energy about
will change with time but it has to be
connected to your purpose
just because it gives you energy it's
not going to fill you up it's got to be
connected to a deeper source which is
your purpose
most people quit on things because they
don't have a powerful mission or they
don't know where their drive
comes from chasing an opportunity isn't
enough because you're going up
against people who love that thing who
might be willing to
die for that thing if you want to go to
mars
you're competing against elon musk who
would die
to go to mars you better absolutely love
it or he's going to crush you
you need to find the thing that you love
that does not feel like
work otherwise you'll end up working
your entire life
and hating it so every thursday when i'm
in toronto
i do this free event for toronto
entrepreneurs at my daint studio toronto
dance salsa 5 to 6 p.m
thursdays when i'm in the city i do a
free event q a session for an hour
come out meet me talk let's hang out
however i can help give back to the
community and help local entrepreneurs
my thursdays are bonkers my thursdays
are all day long interviews hangouts
podcasts
skype sessions one-on-ones my assistant
books them in 25-minute chunks
and i have 25 minutes on minute break in
between
usually i use that break to get set up
for the next one 25 minutes 5 25
5 25 5 the whole day long and then i end
up going to the studio i record my
podcast with mark draker
i then do two 30-minute one-on-ones that
we film for the youtube channel
and then after all of that i do a
one-hour q a
for the entrepreneur community and then
after that i'm doing more meetings with
my team
it's crazy and somebody asked me last
thursday how do you have the energy
for all of that stuff i love it like
i i love being there with the people
that group session is the best for me i
love it i'm not getting paid for it
it's free it's probably not a great use
of my time if
i had to pick for one hour what's the
best use of my time hang out with
startup entrepreneurs ask me their
questions or
or do something like write my book or
make my next course or something else
it probably doesn't make the most sense
but i love it and so therefore it makes
the most sense
right and for other people jumping into
my schedule might be
torture and it should be for me to jump
into your schedule should be torture i
should look at your calendar and say
that's ridiculous how do you have so
much energy for all that stuff
and when you jump in the minute you look
the exact same for me when i gear up for
thursday as an example where i'm putting
my extrovert hat
on i gain energy as the day goes on i'm
not losing energy
by the time i hit five o'clock and i'm
doing the group session with people
i'm carrying the energy of all the
entrepreneurs that i've met
on my 25-minute one-on-ones throughout
the entire day
i love it i gain more steam but most
things
ask me to do almost anything else for
for 8 10 12
14 hours i would hate my life asked me
to make coffee for
for 10 hours a day i would hate my life
asked me to play piano
ask me to do almost anything for that
amount of time i would hate my life
because it feels like work
and so you have to find the thing that
does not feel like work so then when you
go off and do it
it actually gives you energy so paying
attention to the energy
if at the end of every day like oh oh
this sucks
like that's a good signal that you're
doing the wrong thing because you have
michael jordan level talent at something
you are a genius you should be crushing
it
at something and if the work that you're
doing is draining your energy
the people around you are draining your
energy chances are you're in the wrong
spot
you're hanging with the wrong people
you're doing the wrong kind of work
if you want to sign up for the entire
billionaire mindset series for free and
get the companion bonus pdf calendar
check the link right there next to me i
think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there